[Music]
Disney has finally dropped some
information on descendants three yes
that's right it's finally happening
find out everything we know about the
third installment of The Descendants
franchise including the new mystery
character do you love the descendants
are you a VK at heart make sure to
subscribe to the things for more Disney
news Sofia loves Evie Sofia Carson is
pretty much perfection and her role as
Evie the daughter of the Evil Queen and
her social media is perfection - she
posted a tweet saying Oh Evie I love you
it was right after they finished
shooting the first musical number from
the new movie we loved Evie - Sofia we
are so excited to see how easy grows as
a character in descendants three they're
all being pretty hush-hush about the
plot but if Sofia loves her character
this much we know Evie will be totally
amazing in the new movie now if we could
just find out what this musical number
actually is it would make our day dr.
facili a and Celia there are no shortage
of new characters in descendants three
you remember the evil voodoo guy from
The Princess and the Frog
that's right none other than the evil
doctor facili a will be a new character
dr. facili a will be played by Jamal
Sims Sims has been in a few shows but
he's been a professional choreographer
for the last several years we can't wait
to see some magical dance moves
dr. facili a has a daughter Celia Celia
is played by Jada Marine who you may
have seen in ready player one is Cecilia
good or is she evil we can't wait to
find out new costumes
thanks to dove Cameron aka Mel we got a
behind-the-scenes look at the new
costumes for the main four characters
dove dropped this awesome picture on her
Instagram she just loves teasing her
fans mal isn't an amazing purple
ensemble of course and check out Evie's
high-heeled boots with that leather
skirt she's definitely styling J looks
super cool in that jacket
we are totally digging the new looks
especially Mouse new hairstyle
no one rocks the purple hair quite like
mal seriously we can't decide whose
costume we like the best production for
one one
he is great at keeping big projects
under wraps and the senate's 3 is no
different here's what we do know
production is officially starting this
summer 2018 and we know they've at least
tried on the fierce new costumes right
we know that they are filming in
Vancouver Canada we've seen the teaser
trailer with Mal walking in the forest
toward a mysterious blue light and we
know it's going to be totally lit we
hope that the stars will be dropping
more behind the scene Instagram post
pretty soon and we'll definitely keep an
eye out for them too bad we have to wait
more than a year for the new movie
Cameron Boyce turns 19 we are total
suckers for close cast relationships and
the descendants cast is super close on
Cameron voices birthday their instagrams
were just the cutest Cameron's birthday
was May 28 dove Cameron posted the most
adorable selfie with her co-star she
wrote a long heartfelt message that gave
us all the fields and made his laugh
apparently they were together and the
fire alarms went off that's a memorable
birthday for sure in Sofia Carson let
the world know she sees Cameron as a not
so little brother Cameron Boyce himself
shared a selfie of him and booboo
holding the two girls and captioned it
adventures of the Dream Team volume 2 -
cute
can we be friends with them mal in the
recording studio
we loved of Cameron and we really loved
all the behind the scenes photos she
posts on may 16 2008 een she posted that
she had just finished recording her last
ever descendents songs she shared a
photo with the awesome director Kenny
Ortega and some other staff
she said the song is so full of emotion
and she can't wait for her fans to hear
it
trust us stuff we can't wait to hear it
either she called the moment bittersweet
it must be sad but also really exciting
to be ending such a big chapter in her
career we know she'll go on to do great
things after descendants three raps mr.
smees sons
you probably remember mr. Smee as the
devoted sidekick to Captain Hook in the
classic Disney movie Peter Pan
he was goofy and obviously kind of
likable despite working for the bad guy
well it turns out hook isn't the only
villain from Peter Pan to have kids and
descendants three will need his two sons
squeaky and squirming squeaky and score
what kind of names are those we sure
help their nicknames with names like
those we bet they're sort of goofy like
their dad
squeaky will be played by Christian
Convery and squirmy will be played by
Luke Rossler what else do these boys
have in common
Jane and mal Brenna D'Amico plays Jane
the daughter of the fairy godmother we
love how her character has grown over
the last two films and can't wait to see
what's in store for her Brenna posted
the cutest selfie with dove Cameron from
the set she captioned it made with two
hearts The Descendants crew loves to
mash up their names we can see from the
photo that they're great friends we sure
hope that all the cast can stay friends
after the franchise wraps in the
meantime we want them to keep sharing
all the adorable photos dance fever
the official Instagram for The
Descendants movies is so good at teasing
us they keep posting the cutest videos
of behind the scenes photos and clips on
May 25th 2018 they announced that
production has officially begun they
made a compilation video of the cast in
the recording studio and at dance
rehearsals leading up to the shooting
the cast makes it look like so much fun
we know they're probably working really
hard learning the choreography but they
make it look easy we're super stoked to
see all the new choreography and music
mouths unofficial dad we don't know much
about the plot of descendants 3 but and
the teaser trailer mal walks through the
forest to a mysterious blue light she
looks at the life and says dad whoa we
know this is gonna be a major part of
the new movie will we find out early on
who her dad is
will mal spend the movie trying to
discover his identity we've so many
questions Disney according to the rumors
mouths dad is none other than ancient
Greek villain Hades Hades will be played
by Cheyenne Jackson who you may
recognize from American Horror Story do
you think Hades is Mel's dad let us know
who your favorite descendants character
is in the comments and that's what we
know about the senate's 3 be sure to
subscribe for more great videos and
don't forget to check out our community
page on YouTube
[Music]